hello and welcome to feedback killer the
weekly comment show with attitude and a
crap intro this week we're downsizing
significantly get it it's a visual gag
I've been downsized because I'm smaller
downsized guys yes ken Levine
administered a pretty unsavoury shock to
the games industry this week announcing
he is quote winding down irrational
games as we know it the studio famous
for introducing the Bioshock franchise
to the world is letting all but 15 of
its employees go as levine hopes to
pursue a smaller more entrepreneurial
endeavor making replayable
narrative-driven games for the core
player the move is interesting in terms
of what Lavine might come out with in
the future but with an undisclosed
number of people losing their jobs as
the result of basically one guy's
creative whims it's a bitter pill to
swallow our community reaction was
similarly ambivalent dumb decision by
Lavine I don't care about bioshock but i
do not like to see people lose their
jobs no matter what is involved illegal
business aside i have a feeling they
will be able to find work soon i'd be
sad about it if their last game wasn't
BioShock Infinite cuz it sucked well
that's irrational sad news nevertheless
I wish success to Levine in his new
studio and that those unemployed find
work it was a talented team here's a
dare future successes wherever they may
go well that sucks for a bioshock but
I'm not all that upset about irrational
with ken Levine and 15 select employees
from the original team I can see some
amazing games coming about
narrative-driven what the [ __ ] why
doesn't Levine realize that bioshock is
itself a story heavy a narrative driven
game I'm sure he does but the problem is
there are three Bioshock games now
there's an established law and narrative
pattern people expect future iterations
to adhere to Bioshock is an amazing
franchise but it offers Levine less crew
a tivity then a completely blank slate
I'm playing devils have a card oh here
because that's my job but it's not
overly surprising ken Levine wants to
break into something new Johnny yes ebb
you said Devil's avocado did you mean
advocates no so you meant to say avocado
yes so yeah aside all of the people
coming out of the woodwork to go oh good
loads of people have lost their jobs I'm
glad because I didn't love BioShock
Infinite up yours by the way the
majority of our commenters were trying
to work out not why ken Levine lay off
most of his studio but more how could he
at a time where layoffs and studio
closures are unfortunately frequent and
almost universally related to financial
woes Ken's motivations are a little hard
to stomach here Watch why didn't he
leave and let someone else for an
irrational games now many people are out
of work many talented people I might add
selfish selfish decision on the veins
and two K's part I appreciate his output
but does anyone else think that Levine
is an egomaniac he's the Don Draper of
the game's world obviously Levine can
personally do what he wants it's his
company he created it but to just
shutter the company because he's done
with large-scale development to just
fire a staff of that size because he
personally is done and doesn't have the
emotional wherewithal or whatever else
to appoint a successor to maintain a
successful business I really try not to
get too vulgar on gamespot because there
are enough people who do that already
but I kind need to get this out of my
system Delevingne is a childish
thoughtless self-centered massive
sun-baked coagulated Santorum and I hope
to god he's living in a box under a
bridge after his next venture fails when
he run a business you don't owe the
employees who helped create your success
much more than a paycheck and some
stability and those things are not hard
to give people when you're successful
ken Levine is just an soul and it will
be a cold
day in hell when I buy anything with his
name on it that last comment was
obviously pretty long and really rather
graphic in parts but lowkey hero does
ray some good points Levine could have
sold irrational and founded his own
studio or created one alongside it to
handle smaller more creative projects a
bit like popcap did with forth and
battery before EA bought them out
entirely the only problem is both of
these options would probably delay work
on whatever Levine's next project is as
well as stretching his resources a bit
thin it's a messy situation but it is
the most effective way for chem to get
what he wants ultimately my take on the
irrational games closure is this ken
Levine is a truly impressive creative
mind irrational is his studio he can do
what he wants with it and from his own
personal creative standpoint this is
almost certainly a good move from all
other angles though can Naveen is acting
like more than a little bit of a penis I
wish I could be more articulate than
that but words fail me Ken's being a bit
of a flappy Willie anyway now I've like
in an industry giant to a phallus oh I'm
going to kick my feet up and wait for a
cease and desist I'll be back next week
assuming I haven't been sued out of
existence bye bye
you